the Joe Rogan experience so when you do
something like this and you release this
game obviously there'll be patches and
some upgrades and some different things
that you do but how long how long do you
work on this game before you guys move
on to the next thing we're already
moving on to I don't want to say the
next thing that is a PR answer because
I'm not allowed to say that but the you
have ideas already ideas certainly and
and DLC the DLC is guaranteed like is
that it's basically like a small episode
of doom that we would sell and why is it
called DLC downloadable content I below
it that sounds think that anyone would
know what we were talking about id I'm
so used to Jamie but Jamie's a super
nerd I'm so used to the gaming
convention to speak but yes it is down
like it's like an episode like we made
the movie and now we're gonna release
like an HBO series of it
okay so you'll have this game and then
you'll have a bunch of other ones that
are based off the same engine same
characters different journeys different
things that'll come up well all centered
around the doom guy yeah yeah but yeah
basically the adventures of doom guy and
how long do you do that for before you
move on to the next game it's hard to
say you know certainly we're always kind
of dual tracking things and talking and
you know we've always you know because
you never know when the cool idea is
gonna come along and you're kind of
jotting down notes oh I always have kind
of my notepad out just thinking about
stuff like as I'm I mean you never know
when it's gonna something cool you know
you're playing something or you see
something or watch something so and then
we keep those conversations going on the
side and see how it goes so is there any
[Applause]